s'apprête à boucler son sac son groupe
lui a donné rendez vous le lendemain
pour un départ direction l'ukraine voilà
donc ça c'est pour laisser pour les
grands froids d'ailleurs c'est un
sergent je suis pas sûr ça je garde je
le garde pas on change un voile a pas de
signe distinctif d'appartenance et une
armée ou quoi que ce soit thierry est
une figure des gilet jaune il comptait
des en ukraine aux côtés des
humanitaires mais n'exclut pas de
prendre les armes c'est l'europe et
l'europe de l'est on voit les images
c'est terrible il ya des morts il ya des
fans il ya deux millions d'exilés donc
moi je chantais cet appel d'aller là-bas
d'aller sur place de les aider ne
pouvoir pas quelque chose moi les
problématiques qu'il y avait en france
j'ai du sort des dans la rue j allais la
byin problématique donc levé il n'a
aucune expérience des terrains de guerre
il compte sur celles de ses compagnons
de route spécialisée dans l'aide
médicale d'urgence thierry les a
rencontrés via les réseaux sociaux mais
il ne les connaît pas eux ont déjà pris
la route tout seul
comme thierry ils ont répondu à l'appel
du président hélène ski l'un d'eux a
combattu dans les forces françaises et
travaille aujourd'hui derrière un bureau
l'autre enchaîne les petits boulots
après tout on peut y vivent
on peut placer
il est pas de ce qu
il tient à garder l'anonymat leurs
familles ne savent pas qu'ils partent
pour combattre son bonheur de pouvoir
partir la combattre je pense que si un
jour ça se passe en france est bien
content que pas dopé comme sauf
thierry et ce petit groupe de
combattants volontaires espère rejoindre
vive et kiev au plus vite leurs contacts
sur place leur avait promis un passage
de la frontière ukrainienne simplifiée
mais 72 heures après leur arrivée ils
étaient toujours bloqués en pologne